Speaker 1: All right, let's get into audience
questions for the week, a bunch of questions
about the recent 60 Minutes UFO UAP piece
that was done.
The general gist of the question is, is David,
what's your view about the truth of the recent
UFO UAP story?
Now, UAP is a relatively, at least in the
public space, new term for unidentified foreign
objects called unidentified aerial phenomena,
I'm sorry, unidentified flying objects.
The new UAP is unidentified aerial phenomena.
My view on this is I don't think anybody is
lying about what they believe they saw.
When you see pilots interviewed and saying
we saw this moving in that way at the speed
and we don't know this, that.
The other thing I believe everybody so far
is being honest in their perceptions.
I believe we only have part of the story and
I have no evidence at this point that we are
dealing with aliens from another planet.
And this is the most important thing to remember
just because we say there's a UFO that's an
unidentified flying object.
It's an object that's flying and we don't
know exactly what it is, doesn't mean that
it's aliens.
And similarly, an unidentified aerial phenomena
has the sort of same analysis.
Now, I've said before, if there is an intelligent
interstellar traveling species or human society
of some kind that comes to the United States.
If we default to treating it as a threat,
the way, for example, Marco Rubio said these
UAP UFOs are, these are threats.
Well, it may be a threat if they are you know,
if it's spy technology from an adversary,
then we're talking about national security.
But if we did get a visit from aliens and
we treat it as a threat when they are actually
not a threat, if they come in peace, so to
speak, then we could potentially destroy what
would be a historic species changing encounter.
And the reality is that at this point, since
we lack the technology to do what we imagine,
maybe someday would happen, which is some
huge alien race from somewhere else in the
universe comes to the United States.
If they came with nefarious goals, it's abundantly
clear that at least at this time, we would
be able to do nothing to prevent them from
either killing all of us or enslaving all
of us or whatever.
So for me, the national security analysis
makes more sense if we're conceding that the
most likely explanation is that this is either
something from a foreign power.
In which case, by the way, if we really don't
understand what it is, then they are way further
ahead than us in many ways.
And we should be extremely worried.
Or it's also possible that these are unidentified
or unknown to the pilots and people that were
interviewed for the 60 Minutes piece, but
that it actually is classified at a level
above their pay grade or level of access.
And the people who know what these things
are did not participate because maybe 60 Minutes
doesn't even know who they are.
So I think my main point here is that for
me, the most serious approach to this UFO
UAP thing is, first of all, there is no evidence
that this is aliens from somewhere other than
Earth.
There's just no evidence of that.
And it's fascinating to think of and I understand
the equations about the probability of intelligent
life other than just on Earth Earth.
And I recognize that if we were ever to make
that first contact, that would truly be an
incredible thing.
I'm not saying it's not possible.
I'm just saying there's no evidence that this
is that.
Then it gets to the question of assuming that
it is indeed manmade technology, then what
is the source of it?
Is it something American that is so classified
that even the people interviewed don't know
what it is?
Or is it something foreign?
And then you get the people who say, well,
the physics of it doesn't make sense.
There were dissents in altitude that would
have killed any human body that was in there.
OK, maybe there wasn't a human body in there.
We also know that the way a lot of these things
are filmed and perspective and lenses can
make something seem different than what it
might look like to the naked eye.
The where I come back to is sort of an Occam's
razor type question, which is which of these
explanations require the fewest assumptions?
And the ones that require the fewest assumptions
are the visual perception that the pilots
claim is not entirely accurate.
That would be a very straightforward way to
explain away a lot of this or this is stuff
that is known.
It's not unidentified.
It was unidentified to the pilots and maybe
to air traffic control.
But it's technology that higher up we are
aware of or it was human made technology from
some other like from some other country.
The one that is the furthest and requires
the most assumptions, of course, would be
the alien one, which is there is an alien
species that is advanced enough to travel
to Earth from really far in the universe because
we've been observing the universe that's more
immediately around us for a very long time
and to do it without any other signature radiowaves
or whatever else.
And so the number of assumptions start to
go up significantly.
So that's not where I am on this.
Now, just one other thought on this.
One thing I read was.
The information that was released.
Was fake information released by the U.S.
government to trick other countries?
What's the idea here?
This is quite cynical and.
If you go down this rabbit hole, the pilots
interviewed on 60 Minutes could be in on it
or not, they might not even be in it.
The idea would be let's make some video and
have pilots tell stories or otherwise convince
pilots of the reality of this so that 60 Minutes
will do a piece, will have some big reveal
about these UAP UFOs.
And this will be seen by our adversaries and
it will completely misdirect them so that
they will start sinking R&D money into what
they think they need to do to develop these
things.
And it's just it's either digital, it's not
even real.
It's just been made on a computer and it's
a way to get adversaries to spend.
Unfortunately, that's not totally implausible
compared to the alien theory.
The deliberate misdirection campaign by by
the U.S. government strikes me as more plausible.
Send me your thoughts.
That's kind of where my head is on this at
this point
in time.